trente ans d'histoire ça se fait d'abord
rachetée par la commune de montigny le
bretonneux en 1984 dans un état de ruine
la ferme du manet ensuite été réhabilité
pendant plusieurs années avant d'arriver
à sa forme actuelle en 91 on a eu le
plaisir de l'inaugurer avec jacques
chirac qui était maire de paris à
l'époque qui a eu la gentillesse
d'accepter de venir durant les trente
dernières années la ferme est devenu le
coeur de montigny le bretonneux
puisqu'elle sait se faire multifonctions
auditorium espaces de réunion grands
espaces de verdure à l'accueil
convention expositions soirées ou encore
team building c'est l'élément
patrimonial de la ville et c'est un
élément patrimonial qui vit puisqu'il
accueille toute la semaine les
entreprises et le week-end les familles
et il accueille aussi les associations
toute la vie associative
durant ces trois jours de festivités les
habitants sont donc venus célébrer ce
lieu de patrimoine qui fait partie de
leur histoire de quoi rappeler quelques
souvenirs il ya 30 ans mon fils qui
avait 11 ans dans clash de mon petit
fils m'a dit maman il ya jacques
monsieur jacques chirac qui va inaugurer
la ferme du manège je veux y aller on
voit aussi à quel point la ferme du
manège à l'instant j'en parlais avec une
dame qui me dit ben moi j'ai moi même
mon mariage c'était ici est en fait
chaque énigme honte à un souvenir
accroché à cet espace lac est l'occasion
de pouvoir transmettre ses souvenirs aux
plus jeunes
et
lien chan trois centres équestres suis
allé concert il ya beaucoup trop avec le
co vide mais effectivement il y avait
des spectacles mené au spectacle
va faire les concerts une fois par an
d'école les musiques du manet tous
ensemble on a réussi à faire que ben ce
site reste le coeur il avait été de
façon historique et bien qu'il reste le
coeur aujourd'hui de
montigny-le-bretonneux en espérant que
petits et grands puissent profiter de ce
lieu particulier pendant de nombreuses
années encore encore 30 ans de bonheur